whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a Sim at the house in
Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale
[Music]
thank you
how are you guys doing I came across a
video from this man called Patrick Davis
you may know him from his channel called
valuetainment let's take a look at the
video and come back and respond in kind
a bit of the Christian religion have an
influence on but also the Muslim in the
Muslim religion as much as
you know uh people in America want to
make it it's a very peaceful thing
you've heard Bill Maher say this before
what bill says you know most Muslims are
not terrorists but Bill Maher also says
but most Muslims most terrorists are
Muslims right so when you read they're
like wait a minute you can't say that
well it's not wrong right when you have
this kind of conversation there's a part
of it where I think the way the Muslim
Community looks at women it is very
submissive it is very you know I get to
do this and you can't it is very I can
have multiple wives you can't have
multiple husbands it is very you can't
get to sleep around which you know your
body all these kinds of cliches I have
to say are cliches which we've heard as
the Muslim Community all too often
they've been repeated regurgitated
reiterated
and I have to say
they are boring now for us I mean we've
heard this so many times before
doesn't mean to say that just because
of the monotony that it induces within
our very psyches
that it's not worthy of a response which
is what I'm doing here now
uh in this video
I'll say is that there are two
assertions that were really made by this
man
Patrick Davis the first
was one which he agreed with the
proposition let's say that Muslims
uh the majority of terrorists or the
majority of terrorists are Muslims
putting it exactly in the terms that he
put in
now first and foremost what is a
terrorist
let's really think about it obviously if
you go on you know Cambridge Dictionary
or something it's going to say that a
terrorist is someone who uses violence
for political objectives
however if you look in the fields of
political science and international
relations there is no consensus as to
what the definition of the term
terrorist actually means
but what I will say is this
if what we're talking about is the
targeting or the killing of
non-combatants people that are otherwise
not engaged in Warfare for political
objectives let's say
and we look in the historical record for
the last 2000 years
I think it's almost impossible to make
the case that the Islamic civilization
in whichever way you would like to
Define it even the way that say Samuel P
Huntington does in his book The Clash of
civilizations
that in whichever way you wish to Define
that the Muslim civilization is not
the Forerunner in this for example in
fact there was an article that was
written with tabulation that was made by
Navid Sheikh
of course every
kind of tabulation or categorization or
compartmentalization will have some
level of methodological obscurity
problem and limitation
but having said that he concluded
that the Christian civilization
uh was the most in terms of Civilian
death
active in committing them
with 178 million people he States who
have died
in Wars related to the Christian
civilization compared to only 31 million
Muslims uh people that have died as a
result of wars in the Muslim
Civilization now I'm not saying any of
that is good and of course what Muslims
do or Christians do is different to what
Islam and or Christianity is or there's
no necessary link between the two
Notions
but what I will say is
these kinds of historical facts when
they are put forward
they almost always ignored when we talk
about the colonial conquests when we're
talking about the expansion of Spain for
example into the Americas when we are
talking about Manifest Destiny in
America when we are talking about the
British colonial Empire and India when
we are talking about
when we were talking about the 11 Wars
that were
waged by the United States of America of
which
many of them are contemporary to us many
of them are in our own lifetimes million
people died in Iraq for example in the
same part of the world that this Patrick
Pat Davis Davis is from now I'm saying
to you let's be honest and fair on our
assessments what are you talking about
if you want to make a case that there is
something inherently violent about Islam
then go ahead and make the theological
case but of course the word Islam in
this discourse and it was a very short
one 30 seconds I have to say very
cowardly kind of discourse where he was
putting it in in a very conniving kind
of way in his normal podcast Bette Davis
because he wasn't presenting this to
someone who can challenge his ideas very
cowardly but what I was going to say was
this kind of discourse there's almost
always equivocation between the slam as
a religion
and Islam as a civilization of some
sorts so what is the claim that is being
made that Islam as a religion detects
the primary text ah is inherently
violent and if so can you make can you
put the evidence forward
or is it that you're talking about the
civilization in which case how you
define the civilization let's have a
proper discussion about this issue
secondly secondarily I'll say
or secondly he mentions in in making the
argument against Islam for 30 seconds
the issue to or the issues to do with
gender while say in this case is as
follows we've already spoken in my
content you'll find in many different
places where we challenge feministic
presuppositions the fundamental flaws of
feminism the you know why feminism is
false and so on
however what I will say is this it's not
enough to to preach to the choir to try
and energize the base to make the
assertion
that okay well Islam allows a man to
marry four and a woman can only marry
one or that a woman has to be submissive
in marriage
clear
I think for any Fair academic person
yeah that there are differences in
Western dominant Western ethics and
Islamic discourses there are differences
to do with the with the tension of the
individual to the community or the
husband and the wife the family and the
community and so the society
all of these things yes there are
different questions there are different
answers as per
you know which ideology you are looking
at but the question is why would that
make for example Islam false wrong
unfair unjust or any of those things is
there an argument that you're making
here because I'm still waiting
to hear the argument but the point is
Patrick Davis
unfortunately you spoke to Andrew Tate
for five hours and he's one of the you
know voices of traditional family and
hierarchy within households and stuff
why don't you bring these interrogations
to him why now when you're speaking to a
feminist
are you giving her practically
everything you want she wants to hear I
don't think you're conducting yourself
in a very
um courageous uh dignified way and I
will say to you unfortunately you have
not made a satisfactory argument which
is uh worthy actually of any kind of uh
refutation uh uh further than what I'm
about to what I've already said here if
you do want to discuss this matter I'm
always open to discuss the matter and
challenge your views hey
you are you wasting your time on social
media again your brothers and sisters in
the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal